un premier contact timide qui se solde
par un échec
soucieux de faire lever les 700 barrages
qui bloquent le pays depuis plusieurs
jours
le président colombien a tenté hier
d'ouvrir le dialogue avec le syndicat
des parties travailleurs il n'y a pas eu
d' empathie de la part du gouvernement
pour notre cause pour les revendications
qui nous ont conduits à cette grève
nationale aucune empathie avec les
victimes de la violence qui a été
appliquée de manière disproportionnée
contre les manifestants après plus de
trois heures de discussions le comité
national de grève à l'origine dé
mobilisation entamée le 28 avril appelle
le peuple à poursuivre les protestations
monsieur bouquet voyez combien nous
sommes nombreux ici
voyez combien d'étudiants se lève
combien de pauvres cherchent leur pain à
manger la grève ne s'arrêtera pas tant
que vous ne changerez pas la réforme et
que vous ne nous donnerait pas plus de
solutions nous avons besoin de l'aide
des autres pays la colombie traverse une
mauvaise passe en ce moment à cali ville
la plus touchée par la crise les
barrages sur les routes empêchent
l'approvisionnement des commerces
alimentaires et des stations essence une
situation qui commence à avoir des
répercussions graves sur la population
la vérité est que cela nous a beaucoup
affectés car en termes de transport
certains d'entre nous étaient obligés de
rester sur leur lieu de travail
d'autres n'ont pas pu venir travailler
et d'autres encore ont dû marcher
longtemps pour arriver à destination
c'est assez critique car il n'y a pas de
nourriture dans les magasins sur les
marchés a tenté déjà épuisés et nous
devons nous contenter de ce que nous
pouvant acheter dans les magasins mais à
des prix excessifs le retrait de la
réforme fiscale qui visait à augmenter
la tva et à élargir la base de l'impôt
sur le revenu dans un pays largement
appauvris par la pandémie a pour le
moment été retiré mais dans son élan
protestataires le peuple colombien
exigent désormais une réforme complète
de la politique en vigueur
alors qu'yvan bouquet doit achever son
mandat en août 2022